bueno como usted bien lo ha dicho él ha
sido fue votado por el congreso este que
violó directamente a la Constitución
actual margen de la Constitución y
pretendió
disolver el congreso fuera de las
condiciones establecidas por el texto
constitucional y además eh suspender o
en su caso anular las competencias de
los órganos principales del estado entre
ellos los que conforman pues la triada
clásica de los poderes del estado y
otros organismos constitucionales
autónomos pero al margen de la
Constitución por lo que fue bajado por
el congreso José la mente
constitucional sí las opciones entonces
en todo este marco legal que tiene el
expresidente Castillo no Qué opciones
manejan en la mesa sus abogados
Bueno este lo están defendiendo de las
aplicaciones o de la denuncia que de que
ha hecho el Ministerio Público contra él
no por este conspiración y por rebelión
eso se tendrá que ver ya a nivel del
proceso penal el punto de vista político
Ya el tema está zanjado y el Perú ha
procedido a una a una sucesión
constitucional ciertamente que está
generando problemas como bien ha
relatado también le quiero preguntar
José El origen de todo este problema de
gobernabilidad que tiene Perú con tantos
presidentes Se podría decir que en
promedio un presidente por cada año
estamos viendo también lo que ocurre en
las calles el descontento de las
personas que apoyaban el expresidente
Pedro Castillo en rechazo a la nueva
mandataria boluarte Cómo ve las cosas de
aquí a dos semanas no
largo y complejo de explicar lleva
muchas décadas ya de crisis políticas
por una suerte de debilidad
institucional y falta de organizaciones
sin embargo Y eso sería muy largo de
explicar Bueno lo que está ocurriendo es
que el presidente viene el presidente
Castillo había cometido delitos y seguía
aumentando digamos sumando una cantidad
de acusaciones tenía mejor aprobación
que el concurso entonces
la población aparte de la población
estima que el congreso debe disolverse
también para profesiones además hay un
sector de la aprobación que reclama una
asamblea Constituyente así la cosa no
está fácil estamos en estado de
emergencia en estado de excepción con lo
con la con algunos derechos suspendidos
en algunas zonas del país la policía
tratando de controlar o restituir el
orden interno de las fuerzas armadas
bueno José un panorama complicado
esperemos que los ánimos se un poco y se
pueda resolver este problema es
políticamente hablando y civilizadamente
Gracias José por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en France